[A woman wearing a hospital gown is on all fours on a bed, then sits up.]
[She stands, touches the walls, sits back down.]
[She is smiling, laughing, rocking, and tugging at her hospital gown.]
[She sits, stands, speaks, tears paper,]
[She rolls around on the bed.]
[...]
[A  vial of medication is shown and a syringe prepared. The woman is injected.]
[The woman lies in bed with eyes closed. A doctor moves her head and limbs.]
[...]
[The woman lies still while receiving an injection, then moves slowly afterward. ]
[Her mouth opens and closes and the doctor
moves her limbs. She appears to be convulsing.]
[...]
[The woman previously treated is sitting on a sofa, looking around. She smiles.]
[A doctor injects a woman lying down in a hospital bed. She appears mostly sedated but moves her limbs now and then.]
[...]
[The woman seems to have a mild seizure. The doctor stands over her, straightening her limbs if they flail.]
[A bottle of methoquinine is shown, then a table of other vials and a nurse mixing the dose.]
[A bottle of metrazol is shown and the nurse continues her work, preparing a syringe.]
[...]
[The nurse hands the syringe to the doctor, who injects another patient.]
[The patient is initially still but then begins to jerkily move her head and body.]
[...]
[The patient lies in bed, eyes closed, with the doctor's hand on the back of her neck.]
[A man lies in bed, and an attendant is cleaning the area around his temples. He then places an apparatus on the man's head.]
[...]
[The electro-shock is administered and the man's body reacts, turning and convulsing. He goes still, breathing heavily.]
[A woman receives electro-convulsive treatment. Her body goes rigid, then trembles and jerks and is finally still.]
[...]
[X-ray of patient's fractured spine, a result of the convulsions.]
[A syringe of curare is prepared and administered to a male patient prior to electro-shock treatment.]
[...]
[The electric current is delivered, and the patient convulses, at first markedly and then more mildly.]